Speaker 1: We have a very important runoff
election happening in Georgia on December 6th.
It is Herschel Walker versus incumbent Democratic
Senator Raphael Warnock. This will not decide who
controls the Senate. Democrats will control the
Senate, but it will decide. Do Democrats control
5050 with Kamala Harris as the tie breaking vote?
Or do Democrats control 5149 making Kamala Harris
unnecessary or creating a little bit of margin
in case Joe Manchin or Kirsten Cinema decide not
to play ball? Well, as I've told you before,
Herschel Walker, the Republican candidate,
is one of the most if not the most unqualified
candidate for the Senate I can ever remember
covering. I've played for you times where
Herschel Walker has been incoherent, where
he's been visibly disoriented, where he has said
nonsense gobbledygook coming out of his mouth.
All of those examples are nothing compared
to what I'm going to play for you today.
Herschel Walker speaking a mile a minute.
I've never seen this before. This is upper
Herschel Walker on a rant about werewolves and
vampires that I challenge you. I challenge you
to make through the entire thing. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: I won't tell you to keep the faith.
Oh, you have watched a stupid movie late at
night. Hope I'm going to get better. Don't get
better. Watch. Keep watching anyway. Because
other night. The other night I'm watching
this movie or watching this movie called Fright
Night. Fright Night sometime tonight. But it's
about vampires. Although, if you know vampires
and cool people, are they not? But I'll tell
you something that I found out. A werewolf to
kill a vampire. Do you know that? I never knew
that. So I didn't want to be a vampire anymore.
I wanted to be a werewolf. But then, in a way.
Speaker 1: Elected this man.
Speaker 4: Watching this movie and didn't tell
you how stupid it is, doesn't win in the morning.
So I'm watching my TV and this kid watching that
TV vampire killed on our TV. They know it's kind
of stupid, but I'm still watching, though, as I'm
watching this show. What was fun to these kids
who had a vampire in their head at their house?
So they were watching their TV. They don't
watch them on TV. They're watching their TV.
Speaker 1: This is sad, right? Is this sad or
crazy or scary? I don't know. I mean, I think the
scary part is that this guy might be a senator.
Speaker 4: He's a vampire killed on their TV.
So they win this contest to bring this
actor. Now, you all got to stay with me,
Brain. This actor who's a vampire killer from that
TV to get rid of this really real life vampire in
their head. So it is actor comes to their home.
He got all the right stuff. He got all the right
stuff because you got to have a state and got
to have things that kill him in the heart. And
he got a necklace of garlic for that work.
Speaker 1: Is anybody still with us here?
Speaker 4: I don't know what it does, but it
we've got to have a cross go to burn on what
it were. And then all of a sudden, this is what
was so funny about it. And then walking through
the house. This, this, this, this guy has gotten
holy water. He blessed the house. This actor,
now he's all. He breaks in the house is
Hollywood. They walked upstairs. And this
vampire looking real good in this black suit.
Whoa. Less and less. And what not doesn't look
in all good little black suit.
Speaker 1: I guess that's
the connection to the campaign.
Speaker 4: From the ceiling. He floated,
trying to sell it, looking good and cool. And
I'm thinking, whoa, they better get out of that
house and somebody float from your seat and get
out of the house. That's that's not your house.
But as he floated on the ceiling, the kid jumped
behind our hero and they jumped behind the hero,
the guy jumping in front of me. This whole what
to on a vampire for you. He covered his eye.
And he took his hand away.
Speaker 1: We're almost through it. And the reason
I'm playing the whole thing is for you to realize
this was not just 10 seconds out of context. This
was a two minute, unintelligible, hopped up rant.
Speaker 4: He started laughing and he said,
No word. He took the cross. He put it on a
vampire, for he and the vampire didn't even
do anything. He said, that don't work. And
that's the way it is. Not with life and work
unless you've got faith. It is time for us to
have faith. We got to have faith in our fellow
brother. Got to have faith in this country. We've
got to have faith in the elected officials. And
right now, that's the reason I'm here.
Speaker 1: Does anybody understand why
he's there? I don't from that explanation, he
says that's why I'm here. I don't understand
why he's there, folks. Do you understand the
level of despair that we should all feel at
the state of democracy? If this man can become
an American senator, a United States senator,
one of 100 senators? It is extra important
that we do everything we can to prevent him
from becoming a senator. This is a humiliation.
There's a I quite. I'm not exaggerating. Okay.
If I walked into, I don't know, a dry
cleaner, if I walked into anywhere,
an accounting firm and they said CPA Walker
is going to be handling your taxes this year.
And people the whoever comes in speaks like this,
rants like this about things. I'm not hiring that
person. And he's on the cusp of becoming a U.S.
senator. When Rafael Warnock understands the
issues. Seems reasonably empathetic, seems to
understand the process of the Senate. I mean,
what are we even talking about here? Here's
one more clip from this, where it's something
about bicycles. I don't even know. It's wow.
Speaker 4: What we need to do is get rid of those
87,000 RS 80. That's going to go
out to you. Maybe we need a push.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, there aren't 87,000
IRS or IRS agents. It's just it's not true.
Remember that over the next decade, 55,000
IRS agents will retire. So there's a plan to
replace them with 55,000 new IRS agents. In
addition, the IRS is understaffed. There's
going to be a slight increase to staffing.
And in terms of them going after people,
this is the armed IRS agents thing. There's
like a very small division in the IRS. I don't
remember if it's a couple hundred or at the most
like 1800, something like that. Agents who carry
firearms and like they are, they are police at the
end of the day. And police carry firearms at home.
Speaker 4: With the police officer in our school
to protect our kids. That's what we need to do.
That's what we need to do. But yet we got people
in Washington that got in. We all they want to do
it. Let people ride a bike. That's what I'm
senator. Why not just do it? Then Joe Biden
ride his bike because he voted with 96% of the
time with me. He don't know what he's doing. Oh,
you seem to love Joe Biden. I don't
know which one it is, but I think
both of them is wrong because of what we need.
Speaker 1: It's it's really sad at the end of the
day. I mean, it just it doesn't make any sense.
This is this is the embodiment of everything
we should be working really hard to keep out
of public office. It's it's everything. It's
everything. It's personal hypocrisy, a personal
history of not being a particularly good person,
completely ignorant on the issues. I mean, there
there is no checklist of things we should try to
keep out of public office that doesn't include
everything that Herschel Walker is. So let's
make sure if you vote in Georgia, make sure
you understand where and when to vote. There
is a lawsuit currently about early voting.
If you can plan to vote on December six,
plan to vote on December 6th. We will be live
with election results and all of it on that day